the prayer wheel is spinning at last
today Raphael crew gets to open the
first exhibition at the mima he wasn't
going to be denied his dream by the
terrorist attacks in Brussels things are
not the same today you can feel these
sadness but also the will to rebuild
something and the the existence of the
museum seems even more something really
important for us and for the community
the founder is managed to raise six
hundred thousand euros almost entirely
from crowdfunding now they present
different styles just like the painting
of New York artist maya hayuk her mural
takes up the entire room what separates
mima from other art galleries is that
the majority of the artwork is created
on site a lot of those artists worked in
the public eye I in the street for
example and so there is a lake of
representation of this culture urban
culture in institution the museum is
located inside the walls of a former
brewery in molenbeek a district of
brussels known for being a hotbed of
jihadism rafael correa hopes that the
mima will contribute to a positive
change the museum of this goal to really
bring something to the community here
and also chance perspective from people
living outside of Brazil or even in
Brussels the vision have art connect
people and opposed terror especially in
molenbeek